we are back with drew barrymore she's
our first
live in studio guest since the pandemic
began and as we mentioned earlier her
daytime talk show has been renewed for a
second season
it is produced by cbs media ventures
drew also announced she's expanding her
empire by launching a lifestyle magazine
called drew and we're so glad you're
here at the table but drew i
i have to share this just this just came
to me because i wore this flower in your
honor
when i walked in jared on camera five
the jib said
oh a drew barrymore flower i go that's
why i'm wearing it
jared watches you can tell by his
fashion design he's keeping up with you
so i got this and says gail i don't like
that flower on your shoulder it looks
like an open orange wound
just saying man good morning tyler perry
well he's funny tyler drew has a flower
too so i did it in your honor hopefully
you like it
i love it and i like it right away and
i'll like the yellow
mic i'll come bring you some flowers but
i like that tyler's watching
why but i did this in your honor but
listen congratulations to you
on season two because i know how hard
that is but i want to talk about season
one for a second
is it harder or easier than you thought
did you ever doubt
while you were doing the show well
luckily
i was getting to know you you were kind
enough to do the art of the interview
with me which was i wanted to have a
series of conversations uh
before i even launch the show with
people
that i respect so much and then i happen
to
be partners 25 years with nancy javonan
who's nancy fallon married to jimmy
fallon
so i had a lot of experienced voices
that i trust telling me this is harder
than you'll
ever ever imagine and
a part of me i don't know if you know
this about me but i'm a little
rebellious
and i was like you know i've been
working since i was in diapers and
you're not realizing this my work ethic
and i'm self-generated i'm tireless
and i've got this i know what crazy work
hours
and building you know what happened how
did you handle what happened i
i cried in my bathroom several nights
did you wondering
what i had done to myself because a part
of unraveling myself
out of movies was because i wasn't happy
with the hours
that when i go to work at 4 a.m and come
home at 11 p.m for family life
that wasn't okay for my kids and i
stopped working for many years
because i wanted to be a mom that raised
her kids that was
front burner there was no exceptions for
me so you felt overwhelmed and
literally it drove you to tears yes i
thought oh no i've gotten myself back
into that
4 a.m to 11 p.m schedule and hours are
brutal yeah
going for six seven months in a row it
took us almost two years to build this
show you don't know if you're gonna get
a season two we just found out last week
and you have to tell yourself like
you're building all of this not knowing
if there's a future in it but
everything is a building block that will
bring knowledge
um and something learned later so you
can't do it
for a reason you have to do it because
it's important to do it
and now you feel what relieved okay
which is the most
underrated emotion ever it's relief
doesn't sound sexy but it is
yeah i don't know every time you get a
negative covet test i feel relief
yes and that's sexy
can we get that reported that's unique i
i th the the on-screen star of my
uh youth is just saying that that's
something i said was sexy gayle king
i got it that's right it is i so the
talk show's getting picked up for season
two that's
that that's huge number one also you
know
but this is what people say but drew's
so happy she's so upbeat saturday night
live did a parody of you
oh that happening in the beginning
because
and i'm like is that a bad thing to be
willing to be you and i texted yes and
you
said i think it's safe you're good i
think it's gonna be okay
and nan and jimmy texted me and they
were like this is great
because it's saturday night live i
hosted for the first time in 1982. i've
hosted six times it's an institution to
me that i was raised in
it's very reflective of the show we have
drew's news i'm a news junkie
yeah i'm a news junkie yes always
weekend update satirical news is my bag
i love it
and i love the news in general i love
being informed
but i do like finding the good stories
and we have to do our civic duty to know
everything that's happening but we have
to find the positive too so
that's my spin on it but yeah i was
spiraling on the snl because at the same
time
in all transparency i was getting calls
from station managers across the country
going
what is this show they were yes
they were like what is this creature
that has popped out of the box
by herself alone in the studio in the
middle of a pandemic
everybody's losing their mind what is
this so when the saturday night live
came out i was like is this
gonna be a nail in the coffin for me
with these people
and it was actually exactly what you and
jimmy said it was the start of
this is okay and i you know
i just launching in a pandemic was such
an unorthodox thing yeah
and the energy of the world was wild
and so to pretend it wasn't didn't feel
authentic
um i leaned into it which i think was a
little nerve-wracking for
people um and i you're learning on the
job
and as much life experience as i had
where i could put into this job
i'm still learning and i have
um a lot of energy
and excitement and enthusiasm for this
but a lot of humility
knowing that when those stations have a
new job
when those station managers called and
said what is this new show
how did you answer because i'm sure
there are people watching right now who
have not seen the show and they're
wondering what is this new show
um i said you know what i really care
about because
for whatever reason i'm obsessed with
business
and i said you talk to me i will talk to
you we're finding our way we're doing a
show with no guests
no audience yeah it's really just me
and that's odd and that's a new format
and i'm working with it too
and we're finding our way and we
listened to them and we worked and we
a lot of the people that i know who are
in talk shows say
that first year you're really
rearranging the chess board and moving
the pieces around and
getting rid of an idea you swore was
going to work and
it's not or something you weren't that
excited about is like weirdly gaining
momentum
and i know this word pivot sometimes you
just have to pivot and figure it out on
the fly
yes and it seems like you're now
settling into a groove and getting your
rhythm and you seem really
really okay with how it's going i i do
not cry
anymore at all i'm in such a happy state
work is my happy place work is the place
that i'm the least stressed which is
bizarre because
uplifting and launching a
national daytime talk show putting out
an hour of television every day
is um is the incomplete
juggernaut that everyone said that i was
like no no i've got this and i was like
oh i don't have this this is way harder
and it was very humbling
it's hard whether it's dating dating
talk shows just know it's hard out here
for pimp drew barrymore i do very
difficult
you know leading to you we had a clip
from e.t which never gets old to me
and so we were talking about movies
adriana tony average uh we like drew
when she did that
do you ever think about acting anymore
you're launching a magazine
yes now you've got a talk show is acting
just now done and done for you
it's not done and done i i always get
weirded out when people are like i'm
that this is the farewell tour i'm like
why don't we don't we might want
don't do that like what if you want to
come back then is it a maya culpa now
this is the fair realtor
yeah i'm like i don't know what the
future holds every time someone said
what's your board vision for five years
i'm like i have no idea
but tell me what the next year is i can
map it out for you
perfectly i also was trying to build
behind the scenes of the show
a cookbook a magazine uh another line
beautiful i have flower and i'm sort of
building this all up and i know
that the show could be integral to all
of that
but still i just kept going saying i'm
just putting one foot in front of the
other i'm building this
it's not a cookbook too yes you are yes
there's a lot of announcements we knew
there were gonna be surprises we teased
them we gotta think three
cookbook okay i think that i would be in
a straight jacket if i didn't have all
these buckets that i could fill
i have so much going on inside of me
which is why i thought rebelliously i
can handle a show like this
i have so much inspiration on my
tombstone it's going to say death by
inspo
and and rate and raising two daughters
hello to olive and frankie doing that
too
and that comes first that is on the
front burner of everything i do
drew barrymore we thank you the drew
barrymore show by the way airs on your
local stations around the country
you're watching us here in new york it
comes on right after us check your local
listings we'll be right back